not many people get for a living to play
the Lord of hell but the man to my right
does exactly that on Lucifer which is on
Fox Mondays at 8:00 Eastern Time the man
who plays Lucifer himself Tom Ellis here
in the Rich Eisen show how are you Tom
I'm very well thank you rich I am
thrilled to have you here you are from
Wales correct originally yes agent Lee
from Wales and we were just talking as
we were watching the Olympics go down in
in South Korea and I was about to say oh
I have not seen Great Britain and many
of these sports
we're not notoriously strong in the
Winter Olympics
the Brits yeah we're a bit of a mishmash
in our country because it doesn't really
snow solidly anywhere apart from
Scotland hmm and so like we had a guy on
the other day that was one of our
freestyle skiers yes and he's actually
from Sheffield which is where I grew up
okay which is not snowy at all I think
he learnt on a dry ski really strange
yeah yeah I guess that's why Eddie the
Eagle still lives
figuratively - this part of my childhood
because remember we had a we're a
Canadian exchange teacher come and my
school three-year and that was during
that time I think it was whenever the
Calgary Olympics were mm-hmm
Eddie the Eagle Edwards was the who was
the British represented for ski jump and
it was one of the most it was amazing
that he was notorious for being rubbish
we all knew he was gonna come last but
everyone would stay with so British it
was like at least he's trying
it's diskeeper anyone who's ever tried
ski jumping which I presume is no one in
this room yes it just looks apps I mean
where'd you start with that I mean I
guess at the top of a hill I know that
you just figure that you're going to
stick the landing
yeah or the landing will stay to you I
was watching it the other day is
incredible like I said it's a football
field and a half that they cover yeah
you know I've never watched more curling
in my entire life as I have over the
last couple of weeks I am I am just
though hypnotized by it I don't know why
it's got this sort of meditative quality
hasn't it
so slow but fool tell yeah and I don't
even like I'm not really a clean guy so
I'm that even the sweeping it which
sport do you follow mostly in the Winter
Olympics or just in general generally I
mean I'm loving all sport but I am a big
soccer fan I appreciate you
Americanizing them yes auto-translate
already it's okay you know I grew up
watching a lot of a lot of soccer my dad
being from Wales
yes um my only sport and my dad loved
was rugby which is like the national
sport in Wales rugby union okay so do
you ever try I did I'd played a bit of
rugby at school I was never quiet
I mean I'm physically tall where I was
never physically big or big enough but
now rugby union is like that as if you
ever go I have the pleasure of watching
a rugby union in Wales there's two types
of rugby it's so bizarre but this one
rugby union is like the thoroughbred one
the purest one and if you go in Wales
and watch a game when they sing the
national anthem in the Welsh national
stadium but this is one of the most
amazing moments you'll never experience
no kidding well because being from Wales
that the Wales is about coal mines and
it's about choral singing male choral
singing and hymns and so the the Welsh
national anthem has this kind of like
him like quality and everyone knows the
words to it
so have you Tom Ellis who plays Lucifer
here on the Richard show if you had an
adopted American sport is there one that
you have I mean when I was in in the 90s
in the UK they used to be a highlights
package of American football so I used I
learned the rules and I kind of as a
sports fan if you know the rules of a
sports or can appreciate the drama of it
and a lot of people in Britain just have
no clue how American football works so
did you go to the London monarchs games
didn't London Games there was there was
a smaller league that started in Europe
there was a League of America wlaf no
sort of it of that the standard wasn't
great
but but it was goodbye actually lost
your wits the Super Bowl which cash is
the first NFL game I've ever been to
come on suppose you've ever been to
Houston I saw that amazing game between
Atlantis in the patriot now where you
were you one of those members of the Fox
community that they say there's Tom
Ellis they put all of I guess
foreign talent sit together
yep okay I see how it works now and then
[ __ ]
so your first game your first NFL game
you went it was the Super Bowl and it
was an overtime game it was it was the
most incredible game and there was that
incredible catch mendelian sort of was
that was the pivotal point of the game
yes it just got his fingers and exactly
we're all waiting for the playback in
the stadium and then they happen
ridiculous we nicknamed it what do we
name it Chris Brockman the Boston knee
party the Boston Tea Party yes you know
it was amazing it he's a patriot okay
and then and so you threw out a first
pitch at a Dodger game which I've done
that's the most nerve-wracking thing
I've ever done yeah they don't tell you
how far away is today
oh man neither so what'd you do did you
just about hit the dirt just as it was
getting making the pitchers hand mm-hmm
are you though it was alright but I was
very very nervous
well at least you weren't fifth fitty
cent I know if you've seen these voices
but they'd warned me about that one
season it's amazing how he has become
the gold standard of what not to do I
feel well I did I proposed to my friend
it was sort of who set it up for me that
I would go up and and throw a cricket a
bowl like a cricket bowler and I thought
that would be funny as a British person
and he went if you do that everyone in
the stadium will hate you at Tom Ellis
17 on Twitter and you play Lucifer is it
true you come from a religious family
I do anyway my dad is a Baptist pastor
and did you have to break the news
gently to him that you play the Lord of
hell
I mean thankfully I think my family
because my sister is is well my family
are kind of what your sister is also a
pastor and my uncle actually yeah so
yeah you can
paster my dad my sister my uncle and you
and I play the devil I mean listen
they've watched the show and they know
that the show is kind of it's it's a fun
telling of you know using a character
that we all know sure and actually the
original source material for our show
was was from a comic book not not the
big book okay so so we kind of like
we've always sort of steered in that
direction right yeah and I just love the
idea that that the devil's just like you
know been there done that
I just want to I'm retired I was that
was this the hook for me because you
know there's been lots and lots of
stories about the devil and on film and
TV over the years and Ray I loved the
notion that we had a devil who didn't
want to be the devil anymore and he's
never chosen to be that in the first
place
so he's like to know what I'm done with
that but he still has all the attributes
of being the devil sure just um just
doesn't want the responsibility being
consultant for the LAPD and then running
a nightclub yeah for the consultants in
the LAPD sort of happened as a happy
accident in the pilot episode is that
right and but then a TV show was born
out of it fantastic it's just a lot of
fun and it seems like you have a blast
we do we haven't got a great group of
people at work and we really you know
there's a lot of humor in our show and I
think that really we enjoy going to work
and making each other life well it's on
now Mondays 8:00 Eastern on Fox it
returns from its break next Monday right
in the middle of season 3 yes Congrats
on the success of it come back any time
you you damn well please thank you rich
I didn't say darn because you are the
devil you're rubbing off on me I can't
believe it you haven't here you are
literally the dark sheep of you it
happens by osmosis I just spend a bit
more time with my fantastic guy at Tom
Ellis 17 on Twitter Tom Ellis of Lucifer
check it out Monday's 8:00 Eastern on
Fox the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience